business return to office plan may cause
long-term harm workers say thousands of
Disney employees
have a signed petition that is pushing
back on a company's return to office
plan arguing that the four-day Work Week
requirement will unintended consequence
will have unintended consequences for
the company the petition has garnered
over 2300 signatures from employees
across Mickey Mouse's businesses the
workers claim that the Mandate is likely
to have unintended consequences
replace okay go ahead Tom what are your
thoughts on this year with what Disney's
doing well first of all this is a group
of employees that are coming out
protesting the four day work week four
days and remember Iris had two things
we're a creative company come together
to discuss creative ideas and come
together for mentorship and be
identified as potential for management
this is not Igor telling everybody you
will be in the office 60 hours five days
remember this this goes back exactly a
month ago every seems pretty reasonable
but now you've got 2 300 Disney people
that say no no that's even that's too
much we are hard to replace talent and
here it comes represent vulnerable
communities that was what they said so
this happens about two days ago to be
exact yesterday
Wall Street guidance is given and Disney
says well you need to brace yourself
because I think there will be actually 5
000 additional workers laid off wow
that's what they said yesterday so can I
be Bob Iger will you be head of HR yeah
okay hey Vinnie yeah Bob here listen
um I may have to lay off 5 000 more
people
okay we gotta pick 5 000 more people to
lay off uh I got a question for you yeah
if you have that petition handy
I think I have it right here I got it
right here all right Perfect all right
put them on the list tell all those
people that don't want to come to work
that they can work from home for
somebody else got you have a nice day
thank you I bet I think this is so
ironic that people are coming forward
when I thought that Iger made a very
measured good points about coming back
to work on a four day plan some of you
are in traffic in Burbank California
it's just four days and then they go
there and then Disney behind the scenes
is looking for other expenses and so the
unintended consequences a bunch of
people going oh man I signed that thing
yeah
wow Vinnie no I just it's I just felt I
just felt really cool like I had like an
HR job
I felt like I wasn't
Shadow back in my office yeah I actually
think that these conversations are
actually becoming more and more
important the overarching conversation
is this concept of work-life balance and
I think that Disney is just sort of in
the crosshairs of of a greater
conversation this isn't the first time
we've discussed four day work weeks
certain countries I think I believe have
started to implement this Portugal being
one
um versus what you see for instance like
in countries like Japan you see people
that like are so burnt out because their
entire life is just spent working that
they it's acceptable to just sleep in
the streets or they have like areas we
can sleep so I'm actually totally okay
with whether it's countries whether it's
municipalities whether it's corporations
completely having this dialogue this
this you know do you live to work or do
you work to live this is this is a
conversation I think is okay you know
this isn't like nonsensical BS this is
people's lives and their livelihood and
I think these companies conversations
are are are totally acceptable
any thoughts
I mean I come from communist North Korea
there's no weekends right we are
revolutionaries we have to work wow
every single hour from 5 a.m to 10 p.m
so even your child five years old we all
have to be in the first labor I I just I
don't know like you go to work there's
AC there's indoor bathroom there's a
clean water what's the complaint you get
paid for it so there's no work-life
balance in North Korea whatsoever I mean
we don't know the word but I think it's
just so weird like Omega is so soft
people are so lazy can I ask you what
actually I think what she's saying yes
if Bob Iger wants people to work seven
days a week move your headquarters to
North Korea so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]